on one end we have Chris Gardner the
ultimate good guy struggling to make a
life for his son on the other the
ultimate bad guy
Idi Amin in-between a conflicted diamond
smuggler a high school teacher who lives
in an altered state and one fabulous
dirty old man each won a challenge each
one addressed brilliantly by five of the
best actors in this business here are
the nominees for actor and a leading
role and the Oscar goes to Forrest
Whitaker in the last game
Forest Whitaker's Road to the Oscars
began when he earned a scholarship as an
operatic tenor
thank you thank you well I says second
just a second okay take it I wrote
something down because I thought it
would happen I be a little overwhelmed
in I am so okay when I was a kid the
only way I saw movies was from the
backseat of my my family's car to
driving and uh wasn't my reality you
think I would be acting in movies so
receiving this honor tonight tells me
that it's possible it is possible for a
kid from East Texas raised in South
Central LA and Carson who believes in
his dreams commits himself to them with
his heart to touch them and to have them
happen because when I first started
acting it was because of my desire to
connect to everyone to that thing inside
each of us that light that I believe
exists in all of us because acting for
me is about believing in that connection
and it's a connection so strong it's an
action so deep now we feel it and
through our combined belief we can
create a new reality and so I want to
thank my fellow believers in the Last
King of Scotland I want to thank Peter
Jeremy Andrea
Lisa Charles Kevin James MacAvoy Kerry
Steven Fox DNA channel 4 I want to thank
the people of Uganda who helped this
film have its spirit and finally I want
to thank my mom and my dad I want to
thank my wife Keisha my children my
ancestors who continued to guide my
steps and God God who believes in us all
and who's given me this moment in this
lifetime that I will hopefully carry to
the end of my lifetime into the next
lifetime thank you